She looks sleepy cause she is sleepy and it's only day 2 of Gracevember.
Ting Dong!
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now. Welcome to Gracevember.
I'm making a video Monday through Friday through the month of November. Will that catch on as a catchphrase?
Hopefully not. That's a lot to say. It's ThursD-I-Y
here on It'sGrace.
So we're gonna get into some fall home decor, because nothing says "I have nothing else to do"
like changing out the decor in your home on a seasonal basis.
CUTE!
Home decor can be a really fun way to distract yourself from how sad you actually feel. It can also be inexpensive!
It's a fun way to change up your environment without doing a full overhaul, or a full over-fall.
I'm sad inside.
So here's a really quick and cheap and easy
home decor DIYs that you can do to make your home feel more in line with the season, both weather and politically speaking.
*music plays*
For reasons, unbeknownst to me, Me  decided to start this video with no audio, so you get a voiceover and then I'll start talking
eventually and it'll be weird, but our first DIY is a birdhouse! How fall, how autumnal, how festive?
I bought this pre-made birdhouse at Joanne's fabrics for like ten dollars.
But you can also make your own birdhouse if you're a f*cking monster, and then I'm gonna use these metallic acrylic paints.
Which are also super autumnal, that I also go to Joann fabrics, and then I got these brushes also from joann fabrics.
So I'm gonna take my metallic paints and pick a color that I think truly reflects the current state of our world.
Gray! And then this is where I decided to turn off the TV and talk into camera because I knew that my later voiceover would...
...be sh*t. Hey! We're gonna paint it kind of sh*tty and half assed-
cause that's how things seem to be done in our country these days...
...and also the silver is really
reflective so we can see ourselves in it. People that are in the most amount of power seem to only want to look at...
...themselves. Just continue to paint it with the thought of like 'get it done' vs like 'do it well' and here just a lot of...
...noise in the background...
...too that's par for the course. Golf, reference, it's literally par for the course.
So we've painted it a color that fully represents our future: BLEAK.
This is a birdhouse, obviously a shelter meant for birds. It offers safety, comfort, and the hope for a successful future-
BUT in keeping with current trends we're gonna
f*ck with that. I'm making some fun popsicle sticks. These come pre-taped tape so I don't have to do any work. Thank god
Just like the president. And just peel off the tape
And I'm gonna just start sticking them right to the front and there you go. We have now officially
nonsensically and
very poorly constructed a wall in front of a structure
yhat was once a beacon of hope for birds. Doesn't it make sense? Moving on...
Pillows! One of the most cost-effective and fun ways to change up your seasonal decor is with throw pillows.
I found this pillow at Joann fabrics for maybe like
$15 and it's already pretty fall oriented,
but I wanted to make it super specific so one of my tricks is when you see a pillow that you might like the coloring
of- I love this plaid, but I'm not super into this. You can turn it over and make it into anything you want. PILLOWS!
One of the other trends in pillows is to put some sort of quote or inspirational message on there,
so I thought I would take this very fall themed plaid pillow and
put a quote on it from a
person that has a lot of influence. All you need for this is some sort of fabric marker or paint pad and a quote that
you want let's go for it.
*music*
And I'm done. This is a very autumnal, but  also non-seasonal quote from the leader of the free world. Check it out.
Okay, our last fall home decor DIY
uses a wooden crate. These are amazing, you use them for so many different things. I get this Joann fabrics for 10 dollars.
And I'm gonna turn it into a very resourceful
autumnal home decor item.
So you can stain this if you want to go above and beyond. I don't have time for that. Our world might completely fall apart
at any moment, so I'm going to save some time.
One of the fun things you can do, like the pillow, is personalize it, so I have some paint pens here.
And I'm just gonna kind of write a personal message on the front of this.
*music*
Then I'm going to decorate the other end of it.
Now I'm gonna add the last little bit of accents.
Ta-da, and there you have it. A very fall themed garbage can.
*music*
Well, there you go! There were my quick, easy, cheap fall home decor DIYs.
I hope this inspired you. Tag me on Instagram or Twitter if you make any of these at home
I'd love to see what you guys make it home, and do not forget to subscribe to this youtube channel. I'm making videos Monday through
Friday for the month of November and you're not gonna want to miss it. Unless it is something that you're gonna want to miss, in
which I respect your opinion.
Thanks for at least giving it some time. Other than that, I don't know.
*BARK BARK BARKBARK*
*mumble* Those are fireworks. The Dodgers just won game six.